when you think of snacks at a ballgame
you think hotdogs Cracker Jacks peanuts
pretzels and of course grasshoppers okay
maybe you don't but the Seattle Mariners
and their fans sure do
so how did this crunchy critter get a
spot next to your everyday concession
snacks at Safeco Field it all starts at
this restaurant with this guy my name is
Manny Arzo I'm the executive chef here
for Kito's the grasshoppers our
grasshoppers you know they're a delicacy
but they're also a snack I put them on
the menu here as a novelty when we open
and we kind of just spin on the menu for
almost six and a half years I describe
them crunchy like a sunflower seed salty
a little bit spicy every once in a while
you get one that's a little squishier
than he'd like we just toast them and
then we put salt needs some lime and
some chili on them and that's about all
we do to them
it's one thing to see restaurant success
but Manny's grasshoppers became the
highlight of going to Mariners games
when the Mariners cuisine if we'd be a
fit for them I sent some out the
response was unreal as in 300,000 plus
grasshoppers sold they were selling out
you know before they even the first
inning and I started off with 50 pounds
thinking like oh this will last us you
know
a month or two it lasted us one day date
we've probably gone through about a
thousand pounds people want more than
you know hot dogs and popcorn and nobody
else have been doing it at the stadium
so it's kind of one of these things that
I think people just really latched on to
and the popularity far exceeded my
expectations
[Music]
you
every look is an exotic food a paramour
less Portia you tell me look for you
would worm is magic in California
it means sir those load non-forest try
cough syrup and I use that window
[Music]
acaba gob of Endora I'm a Kaffir uppity
person you belong since birth after you
had a boy for you support from stuff
difference of how am i something utility
for Camilo is mark Akita Pilates are
some bankrupt saw only here in the
barangay alchemy luckily Pama patina
convoy bureaucracy Lhasa
a young tobillo determine determine
mahira Hannah P hersheimmer IVD to
suffer garbage cement wouldn't reveal of
an Ebola for the Tsukuba kana aneema
gita monument Sekou motifs pitaka GU
modulo n bun total maker ambien Mila
Mannion under PA you can automatically
young Camilla for Mohammed in a syllable
[Music]
Tamila for during serving a young spirit
Angela than 4000 Lunia pardon young kena
Enya
Topanga do you mean I an amazing move
out
elegant Pune world young silly hat seal
Imahara fuel well I'm getting too big
young saucer a me look who is up around
ulster support then Perrin make hunting
amis human an example for you you can
end up winner would a young Camilla poor
is actually but unknown she's in the
whole world
para mañana para SE Cupp am campbellot
miss wrap myself Novus era el Amazonia
tenemos two universes reduct por ejemplo
L chant occur
productos que cualquier esta Bronte de
tresses trade mission en el turo los
sierra tener es un de ver el que tengo
el de poder mostrar esta cocina
yo tengo la oportunidad de de contar al
mundo colada
[Music]
my nombre is conclusion is Seto
so um cocinero especially southern
cocina Masonic yo Chrissy dentro la
cocina de una cocina Francesa guna
cocina americana una cocina traditional
Equatoria 'no pero nunca me hablar on de
la cocina Mazzoni de todas cuando vengo
de beer ALP weed okay medo de cuenta de
que hay una nueva Cocinita Conoco cena
es conocida para ESO me - Veera Selva
dentro para poder entender en realidad
que es la cocina Masonic Oh siempre que
i un producto nuevo que una persona
quiere lova probar por primera vez
siempre hay una resistencia hace a low
des conocido les damos a pro bar
enchantix ER okay del gusano de lama
sonia lo venko como me a trave oh no
Meah Trevo pero el momento que se a
traving hasta ahora no ella Grado no
hemos encontrado 'no persona que NOS
diga que el chant ocurro que el gusano
Ella's aparecido FeO L chant occur Ozuna
a las cámaras emblematic 'as de la
Missoni Adela quad Oh
a parte de la Tribune a propiedades
Curitiba's contra la gripa comm problema
respiratory OHS - descent ocurro es algo
que puede tener una / en sia algo
diferente pero que el sabor es muy bueno
y sobre todo la porte a nutritional que
le hace a la persona a mia fortune a
demente en todo el recorrido ke mo
sechin Amazonia nada dejado de gustar me
todo para - yo Rico yo vivo con ven sido
del que la cocina Masonic a tiene que
tener el mismo respeto que el resto de
las cosas son pronto nutria TiVo's y que
trabaja ska muna Buena technique a
culinary op Weyden estar en cualquier
cocina sin quest race most people think
this fruit smells terrible it's been
described using words like rotting
onions or raw sewage not this guy though
it's a very good smell to me
[Music]
my name is Chang tak seng they call me
do anything I'm a farmer I'm till now
nearly 30 years selling beauty beside
they called me dear anything
if you're not that familiar with durian
it has a spiky rind and the inside is a
yellow soft colored creamy fruit it's
native to Southeast Asia and because of
its odor is actually banned from many
public places urine is forbidden in a
PHA in hotel some places they put a
signage that no children allow the smell
you can hide my record is about 100 feet
I can smell you red
besides having a distinctive smell
durian also has a distinctive taste it's
like a peanut caramel they have five
flavor Street flavor
alcohol flavor bitter flavor flower
flavor and Nam taste
daughter of five flavor Nam taste
literally means your mouth will go numb
wow I can feel the numbness freshly
dropped Duran
the flavor is so good even the bees come
to the near end this might well be my
new favorite fruit people in general are
divided on this group those who love it
love it the durian is so tasty
it's much better than it smells if you
really like Duran there can be like some
people may look like crazy like
breakfast lunch dinner
treemail are ordering they can eat five
seven fruits per day and there are
others who just can't get past the smell
I smell like Oh what they chase for
durian saying it is the perfect fruit
either you like it or you hate it
some people they don't give chance to
taste but people to try once in your
lifetime
[Music]
some people say it smells like decaying
garbage or rotten meat or smelly feet
but nope it's stinky tofu stinky tofu
has been fermented and gives off an
intense smell while mostly found as a
street food throughout China here in
Taipei one woman has given the state of
home what it means each other should be
was synthesis Chi Chi Chi Chi Toto's is
a total drama a YouTube system don't you
- aunt / oh yeah either I talk [ __ ] ji
jin-hee buccola not vomit ideas in yeah
totally Ella
Hydra debacle told no delay attendance
ojas open beer and a good stink all
starts with a good brain wasa Fonda
transom oh ho ho chi mei li Dunedin
fasciae
con todo en todo bien and assorted
Neapolitan kuchela it sanguine not
happen que la gente que yo Fenway tada
stray pitcher on low-medium for tiny
Tina trading Hitachi soon yah yah yah
yah yah yah
[Music]
go Ganges our honey and tea party event
a pancake
yippee invented half way she saw 2008
Joe Pesci so the trivia talk about patio
you eat Tokyo you had none and for Miss
Wu it's not only about the taste
wait'll ya see ya knock Lin Silla
central welcome
Yahtzee the door soon Oh Pattinson TV
AHA here it hasn't based on channel
you'll need the show sure he says how
were you when he was in Maryland Jockey
come even go sure if I hurt you none of
the Cindy they're all party that but for
most of Taiwan it's about the taste
wait open personal silicon tall cases
yeah yeah yo pizza man you trying on
shinta sold off just a woman Tywin saw
she had the easel Precision's moral of
the story don't judge a dish by its
stink
[Music]